♫ Let's all go to Gullah Gullah Island
♫ Gullah Gullah
- [Narrator] Remember
Gullah Gullah Island,
the ‘90s kids show on Nick Jr.
featuring a fun family and a
polliwog named Binyah Binyah?
(fun music)
Well, it's a real place, kind of.
- [Natalie] I'm Natalie Daise,
and I played Ms. Natalie
on Gullah Gullah Island.
- [Ron] My name is Ron Daise,
and I served as the dad.
(clicking)
- Show me how old
you are Shaina.
- Five.
- [Ron] There is no real place
named Gullah Gullah Island,
except on TV.
It is based on the Gullah Geechee culture,
which was passed on by
enslaved West Africans
who were brought to this country.
- [Narrator] Gullah Geechee
culture was born out of
several African cultures and languages
brought here by enslaved people.
Everything from cuisines
and traditional practices
have been maintained through
generations of settlement
in coastal villages in
Georgia and the Carolinas.
- I am Gullah Geechee and proud of it.
It's important to me to make sure that
Gullah Geechee culture is preserved,
because it's a very important factor
of American cultural heritage.
- [Narrator] When Natalie
and Ron got the opportunity
to present their culture on
TV, they jumped at the chance.
- [Natalie] By the time we
met the woman who became
the executive producer,
we had been traveling
around the country doing stories and songs
of Gullah culture.
That's what we did.
In the beginning we
didn't know that it was so
significant; there had never
been a show like that before.
We wanted a show where our
children could see themselves.
We actually ended up with a show where
everybody could see themselves in us.
- [Narrator] Before we
go, would you guys mind
singing us out?
(laughing)
- [Natalie] Man, we get asked that a lot.
♫ Come and let's play together
♫ In the bright sunny weather
♫ Let's all go to Gullah Gullah Island
♫ Gullah Gullah Island